so I wanted to talk about glutathione
it's one of the most powerful
antioxidants in your body your body
makes it and you can also get it from
your diet because it's a sulfur compound
it's high in foods that are high in
sulfur like cabbage broccoli cauliflower
radishes all the cruciferous vegetables
ok saluteth Ione helps prevent the
damage to yourselves
it has anti-aging properties it helps
detoxify xenobiotics or chemicals in the
environment I mean every year we have
like thousands of new chemicals in the
food chain in your environment in your
lawn
let's say you're a golfer you're gonna
be exposed to you know the chemicals on
the grass so it's you constantly being
exposed living on planet Earth so over
time glutathione gets depleted when you
get older when you get stressed out when
you get infections when you consume junk
food and you make sugar when you're
exposed to a lot of pollution and if you
had an infection okay so it over time it
gets depleted so when to take this
that's the question well let's say
you're you're on medication right now
and you know that's gonna create some
cellular damage I would highly recommend
taking and if you're on a medication
like a lot of people on a lot of
medications or your environment there's
a lot of pollution like last weekend I
went to LA and I couldn't believe the
air quality was so bad I mean I just I
could feel it in my breathing so if you
live in LA I would definitely consume
more glutathione or start consuming the
cruciferous vegetables or if you want to
get a concentrated version you could do
it in a pill form as well so you want to
start increasing this in your diet so
you would also want to take it if you
experience more stress in your life if
you have some disease let's see if
Parkinson's or Alzheimer's or diabetes
or any of those diseases or chronic
inflammatory diseases or rheumatoid
arthritis this is gonna really help you
counter those effects or let's say
radiation radiation can destroy
yourselves let's say you're a pilot or
you fly a lot and hi all
you're gonna get exposure to more
radiation or you had a lot of x-rays I
was an x-ray tech before I was a
chiropractor I used to go in nursing
homes and take x-rays and I would never
and I know this is bad I would never
wear a shield I would just take an x-ray
like a foot away because at nursing
homes you have people that couldn't hold
the breast so I had to be really tricky
to come in the real fast and catch in an
exhalation to get the chest x-ray or
there would be movement so I didn't have
time to you know prepare I probably
should have but I didn't but I was
exposed to the radiation so this is
something that I consume on a regular
basis that isn't actually I know it's
helped me or you're exposed to mold so
it's very important to take this to slow
down the damage to your cells
all right thanks for watching hey you
probably already subscribed but if you
haven't press this little button down
below and I will keep you updated